foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
gamble three times the loss have you
ever been on black
what are you boys do what do you fellas
do
uh either one huh sorry instead of being
huh
compliance for what what is that exactly
oh Wells Fargo okay so something bad
[Laughter]
Finance wow that's hilarious you guys
look like you sell chili dogs
[Laughter]
you have two eating hot dog businesses
across the street from each other
[Laughter]
but you're both White Collar
Finance guys interesting wow Rob's with
Steve Harvey we'll talk about Steve
Harvey
we'll talk about America's favorite
comedian Steve Harvey it's crazy that it
took 80 years of Television to
figure out the perfect television show
which is a combination of Steve Harvey
and the legal system
every iteration a judge show none of
them ever worked said Mathis
well how many were those people Court
Mathis Judge Judy Judge Joe Brown Joe
Brown and Mathis are going to assume
they won for a while called Texas
Justice you're gonna see that one
it's crazy because it was small claims
but you get the death penalty that show
was
it was wild
yeah I don't I don't want to just do a
thing from the the podcast but man the
mental image of Steve Harvey being a
judge at the Nuremberg Trial
[Applause]
that one got me good I was thinking
about that for a while they did what
with the trains
[Applause]
six million
child in my Germany
they did this in my German not in your
mama's Germany hey what'd you want to be
as a kid
you wanted to be an event planner and
you couldn't even get over it
you couldn't even get over that hurdle
it's very do
it I wanted to go to the Moon
I just wanted to plan parties and I I
just wasn't cut out for that I just no
one came no one ever came
it was just me in a charcuterie board
and I would you get a degree in college
in
Hospitality oh so you got what you
wanted and the market was not they're
like no not blonde enough
freed is not legal here is that right
yeah Nebraska what are you guys doing
okay
what's happening
oh that's legal well I flew your Delta
so
foreign
[Music]
oh nice
are you selling it because it feels like
yeah
how did you meet her how did you become
lavas
Craigslist holy
[Applause]
oh my God
well I look forward to seeing you guys
on 48 hours
[Applause]
I honestly don't think you're supposed
to have a relationship from Craigslist I
think you're supposed to get a couch and
maybe something in the parking lot but
that's it
everybody knows you go to the basement
for political opinion
sounds tense
why do you think I'm doing this for a
living you think I was a football player
I'm a go ahead
there's nothing you could say to me I
haven't said six inches from the mirror
you're the first name going in my
suicide note tonight
now's the time I need you on my side no
no that was the most racist joke ever no
I I got like four more in the chamber
wait don't drop the scarf man that was
three dollars at Dollar Tree man
could I embarrass your son is this like
the son of a porno what the hell
if you embarrass my son
a stepson I I could have told you that
is that your stepmom
I wish
[Applause]
it's lovely to meet you Mrs Sarver
who is that
is that really your son and you're just
unfortunately
Phoenix is weird
I wish it was messed up
I know I've got the number of a great
therapist and
he's gonna be like he's gonna be like
there's a picture I really want to plug
my mom out there it was going to be like
me too what
are you here with are you here with your
husband
he passed uh doors open bro
and I'm very sorry for your loss I just
this is
the lowest I've ever stooped in my
comments
thank you
[Applause]
it's gonna be an awkward car ride man
that was a really weird thing the
comedian just said it was so weird
even weirder if we did it right
totally strange
yeah we totally can't have sex with mom
and son
you look like a model dude an Indian
model
I don't know if it's a great compliment
it's like saying you're a Kentucky 10.
you know what I mean
you have all your teeth
was he a model
you don't know you don't know
for you ooh la la you don't know what he
did before you at all
is he that Indian he lives in a shroud
of Mystery
don't ask me about my before days
this guy was an Indian assassin just
sniping off
Elephant Back
we can only wish
your boyfriend now nice first Indian guy
for you nice
is it weird
does this family's house smell weird
you want to know
all right where'd you meet at
School nice you were copying off his
paper I trust
give me the love story was it online is
it on the internet what is it
what did you mean
at a show uh to the guy she used to be
married to was a fan whoa
holy
used to be married
band and then you were playing at that
same show
you were also attending the show and you
were in the audience or were you
backstage
yeah you were in the audience when your
husband was on stage what playing and
your husband is just saying I
don't know exactly you mean no world to
me
he was rubbing on this guy's dick
I hate this guy
you're the only thing I've Ever Needed
hope you're not someone right
now
did you guys do you guys at
that show or that night of that show no
long oh okay okay but then you met and
then how did it you met that night you
changed numbers right and no ran into
each other oh black oh you were like
good to see you good to see you yeah
it's legit dude I don't care if
you broke up a marriage it means nothing
to me I'm not related to her so
my cousin you know how are you
guys these seats always make me laugh
it's like the Last Supper you're all so
uncomfortable
you don't even know each other you're
smashed together
right you look so uncomfortable right
now sir yes you are a little bit no I
know I mean you're looking me up and
down it's making me
no you're not
you have a friend that reminds me of you
who I who do I remind you of
nobody
continue the show
do you know who you're talking to right
now
continue the show that was amazing I'm
the last person you would ever say that
to if you've seen me before
have you ever seen my comedy
no
you want
who knows my comedy knows that oh this
is amazing you're waiting okay
let me explain what's happening
you're gay and you're an alcoholic am I
right
okay
go on with the show
reminds me of that of their entitled
Rich Jewish people that I grew up with
make me laugh
and he's laughing by the way for the
young white girls who are like this is
horrible I feel so bad for that gay guy
in the front
I feel so bad like she's being so mean
to him he's dying laughing so you can
relax
because everyone else is laughing but
it's the young white girls who get tense
now and they're gonna worry all
week about you you're having a blast you
and I'll end up keeping in touch we're
gonna end up we'll go to brunch
and you guys will go to your therapist
this week and be like there is this big
Jew this
this angry Dyke on Stick no you won't
say Dyke you won't say that God forbid
you will never say that word and anyway
I guess
thought I was ethnic looking because I
have dark hair but I'm Austrian and
polish from New Jersey like there's
nothing going on and she's like what's
your background
what's your background
where are you from what's your
background so I was like
[Applause]
I love you
it's all right this is all being filmed
it's all I care about
they have four cameras here now I'm so
happy that was just on tape you have no
idea oh my god oh thank you
thank God that wasn't semen
do I wrap it up or do I keep going until
we get kicked out wrap it up
and leave you can leave get out of here
you can go
it's okay you can leave
no I'm good but I want a receptive
audience so you can leave
you don't have to be there it's okay
was it to be funny or do you really want
to leave because you can leave it's okay
awkward I do a million shows
oh You Wanna smoke you can go what's
that
[Music]
are you his like PR guy
that's hilarious like I'm his manager
and I always sit 30 rows behind him
how I look out for Kayvon best
kavon's best interest at heart from afar
I'm like a guardian angel in the
Darkness
what is your relation to Kayvon or are
you just a fan
okay cool is that true
did you get them on Fiverr
what's crazy you're so passionate about
Kayvon and you're like the farthest
point in the room
it's okay do you want to smoke or you
can you want to stay it's up to you
sure
it'll be good A lot of people are
invested in cave on here you know like
treasure
I feel like a substitute teacher and
you're the coolest kid in class and and
now I'm learning like oh that's just how
kvon is you don't know
Kavon
you must be new
I barely pay attention when the real
teacher is here
I think you're gonna tame Kayvon
I'm a wild horse I take smoke breaks and
I'm 13.
I don't want a vape I like the damage
I don't want popcorn lung I eat that
and now what I'm gonna say is not worthy
of you even staying here it's gonna be
such a bad joke that like you would have
been like yeah I should have left
all right I just gotta get these I gotta
do these guys
isn't it funny like how far poop has to
fall in a porta potty
are you glad you stuck around okay fine
you almost missed that gem
huh Houston ah there you go that that
guy's an undercover cop clearly
how you doing sir good to have you all
right there we go
I got a Hispanic Indiana Jones here in
the front row there nothing wrong with
that yeah all right
Anna baby all right good to see you this
is weird this is actually my my sponsor
so uh trying to cut back hey where the
hell have you been you good
all right this guy's housed well
look I can't talk I gotta get a big cup
of whiskey here so I'm with you
all right cool
um well that was a hell of a start huh
thanks for coming back I hope you hit up
hit a bump because uh
just want to keep make sure you're good
you got a yak you cool
I don't know what that means but all
right
that was the drunkest sign language I've
ever seen yeah
all right all right there you go you're
like a shit-faced Spider-Man
all right you good okay cool you just
keep throwing at me all right there
we go
you're like a magician but nothing's
happening all right
all right
there you go all right your friends are
clearly embarrassed but all right here
we go
you can't blame them but thanks for
coming out good to see you horrible hat
here we go all right ah I'm just kidding
you look great all right I think
you got Landscaping Duty in a minute but
all right there we go
overalls farming dude important it's
important do you grow crops
you don't grow crops no you just want to
dress like a three-year-old girl
your hair like it's freaking me the
out I'm like this is what my daughter's
gonna look like but she's a guy
hey dude I respect it
back that man's Choice dude you know
what I mean to dress up like one of my
kids dolls and
very weird man you're very strange
but like your uncle drawn to you though
you know what I mean like I'm
simultaneously drawn to you and away
from you like
like do you check his uh basement
[Laughter]
dude
you gotta check the basement you know
some people having fun some people
aren't you know
your mouth get dry on edible salad
look at each other for every joke you're
like are we at jerk off instructions
family
we are
coming tubby uh
[Laughter]
[Applause]
families are fun because you guys can't
laugh at sex jokes you gotta act like
none of you have ever had sex but the
evidence is right there dad got in at
least one good load right
isn't that kind of fun to think about
we're all just alive because our dad
went
because Dad went take that
something to think about tonight when
you're alone uh with your thoughts uh
we're all just walking come from Daddy
yeah I'm pretty high
how do you feel about it I'll be real
about it oh we do it I just got
did we already go over this yeah there
he is the gun yeah
calling Dr Come a Little Kiss reference
if you're into classic rock why is he
being arrested does anyone know
Stormy Daniels for dating a
that's why you're being arrested that's
not a good enough answer to explain to
someone who has no idea about the
situation
why is he being arrested
he paid her off what did he paid her off
like what was he trying to keep quiet
yeah that just that he had sex with a
prostitute she's a prostitute
he had a small penis these are all very
different things
that he had sex with a prostitute that
she had a full Bush that he has a small
penis I'm Donald Trump I can't have
people knowing that I a chick
with a full Bush there's no way that the
American public can handle the fact that
the president is uh these Bush
ladies
you ever see a full Bush now
it's surprising
do whatever you want but it is
surprising
you know you're you're gonna hook up
with some Che you go back to your house
take your pants or wow
wow it's like Land of the Lost down
there
to go try to finger Blaster and
she's like that's not it you're off
just guessing it's like it's
like the Angkor Wat temples through this
through the jungle you don't
know where it is
full bush
the problem is men's full Bush it
doesn't matter you still know where our
dick is
[Laughter]
the dicks are Bush proof
you ever shave your dick
you never have
what I do is I shave slices off
all right guys listen I've lost this
crowd already
I'm happy to be here tonight so I'll
tell you I'll I'll say it
um
I will say it
god dude the French man
people are rude in France man I said
hello to a guy he said no
my problem with OCD I have to take it if
I'm in a relationship because with OCD
are you bad in a relationship really how
so
maybe you don't tell me master you tell
me
oh you're not dating
oh oh yikes you're in that position oh
my God I'm so sorry baby boy you're in
this position you're in this no we're
not as she snuggles up to you we're not
I'm never touch his penis ever
and I love him and make him go on weird
dates with me that aren't really dates
but they're kind of like dates and they
feel like a date to him but they're not
what the
what the you said Jimmy in the up
in the balcony said you
Mr or some what's your beef
with Jimmy you girl
how you not hear me when I have a
microphone
[Applause]
you Jimmy let's go dude
what's your name you Jimmy girl
nobody managed to Trader Joe's what the
what the you made candles with your toes
and what the hell it's kind of hot
I with it all right anyway
that's a weird one to yell in bed get
that ass Tabitha sounds like you're
talking to a pickup truck you know I
need new bomber brags and fluid for
Tabitha
call you yeah just call the county jail
and they'll put you on who dragged you
your mom thank you Mom
I'm a generational act do you understand
this
it's incredible what's your name is
Rachel and
Rachel and Deborah how is your name
older than hers
Deborah Jesus Christ
will you Gertrude the
oh Deborah what are you thinking Mom
when was your birthday Deb
July you don't ever give your actual
full birthday
July okay that's good
how's what'd you get
anything cool
trauma
pause on the show
trauma what happened someone hit you
your stepmom got oh you gotta relearn
what the word trauma is
[Laughter]
my stepmom didn't talk to me wow
so much youth it's so beautiful
drama
this is actually a perfect setup I'm
this is gonna feel like a plant but you
know
trauma
all right hold on I gotta figure stepmom
yelled at you for what
going out with Rachel the entire time
you spend too much time with your real
mom shut up
mom cooks better than you call me Mom no
you you I'm calling this
trauma dear diary
you know what Atlanta did you have to do
your greatest Catholic then did you have
to give up something for Lent when you
were a kid yeah you know if you guys
should know during Lent if you're a
Catholic if you ever is the right way
you have to give up something for 40
days because Jesus no one knows why uh
that's gonna be tough because I'm a big
I don't know how I'm not gonna slip into
some clam for 40 days anything for you
Jay dog
nobody believes that James talk with our
sins yeah
I'll have you know you're correct
your pussy's overrated give me a nice
warm book I'll come any day
[Music]
look s finished when I want them too
hot
happy I don't know
Mary
how old are you I um
I bet there's a follow-up
why are you asking why I'm asking
how old she is
yeah of course I was gonna lead into
something
what do you think I have no control over
what's happening up here
this is
awesome I never I didn't I didn't plan
for some Pinot Grigio dump white
lady in the front
to start clamming up the job
[Music]
so
let's pretend that never
I gotta start making decisions like do I
want to have kids you know
oh the lack of enthusiasm is so painful
for the future of society
no one was like you're a joy
everyone's like kids
early
unless right now I'm a King Shame
it's horrible
are they hot right
say James
you've all been on the plane I've seen
the fight locks
I feel like none of us are rich enough
to it to be honest with you
you really gotta be in a high
Echelon and be like you know what I'm
into that now that's like the fog wrong
career
cut off the cameras
[Music]
oh I hate it when people cry after sex
[Applause]
[Music]
at joke world
and that world is wrld
foreign